bro
cowboy fans
hey
stop talking about your cowboys
uh your cowboys suck man they've sucked
for 27 years when we gonna stop talking
about
the cowboys like the america's team
can we stop it already if anything's
america's team it'd be the patriots
they won seven super bowl or six super
bowls in this time frame
and i'm just trying to say i'm tired of
you i'm tired of dallas cowboy fans
you know it's just like what do you have
to what do you have to show like when
you watch espn and these things and you
see all these ex-cowboy players
like you know on tv trying to hype up
the cowboys they get excited every
single year they're like oh man
we got the defense now we got the
receivers we got this we got that we got
this and you think to yourself like all
right maybe they're right and every
single year the cowboys
fail